der krieg in der ukraine geht
unvermindert weiter russische truppen
setzten den sturm auf das stahlwerk in
mario pohl fort in der eu schnitt man
ein weiteres eher sanktionspaket und das
deutsche kabinett berät in einer klausur
über die folgen des krieges und der
ukrainische botschafter nennt den
kanzler eine beleidigte leberwurst weil
er sich nicht auf den weg nach kef
machen will solange steinmeier nicht
willkommen ist der oppositionsführer
dagegen der reiste heute in der ukraine
märz in kiew scholz genug unser thema in
der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
ich bin wirklich
vollkommen erschüttert nicht nur gewesen
dass man auch diese bilder gehen nicht
mehr aus dem kopf und sieht was da auf
zerstörung stattgefunden hat
kulturzentrum kindergärten kirchen
krankenhäuser völlig sinnlos wahllos auf
die zivilbevölkerung geschossen worauf
beste angerechnet werden schwere waffen
so was kann man nicht
die zahlen sind allein gesehen das mich
noch einmal gesehen haben um die ganze
tragik auch solche angriffe zu erfassen
friedrich merz heute abend nach seinen
gesprächen in 44 mit den gebrüdern
klitschko ganz herzlich willkommen zu
dieser runde aus berlin ja die reise des
oppositionsführers ist das ein zeichen
der solidarität oder doch
innenpolitisches kalkül vor zwei
landtagswahlen
darüber und über den ukraine kurs der
regierung spreche ich jetzt mit diesen
gästen eva quadbeck ist bei und
stellvertretende chefredakteurin und
leiterin des hauptstadtbüros des
redaktions netzwerks deutschland nd ich
begrüße ralf fücks der ehemalige grünen
politiker leitet gemeinsam mit seiner
frau marie luise beck das zentrum
liberale moderne engagiert sich seit
langem für die ukraine und war vor einem
monat auch selbst in kiew ich begrüße
die eine bednarz sie ist juristin und
publizistin und auch mitglied der cdu
und herzlich willkommen jan von aken von
den linken bis 2017 war im bundestag
jetzt ist er als experte für außen und
sicherheitspolitik bei der rosa
luxemburg stiftung schönen guten abend
herr van aken frau quadbeck wenn man das
sieht friedrich merz heute in kiew und
in europa hat er sich um getan hat sich
alles angeschaut hat mit dem präsidenten
gesprochen mit dem parlamentspräsidenten
und auch den brüdern klitschko treibt er
sozusagen den bundeskanzler der gesagt
hat er fährt erst mal nicht mehr auf
jeden fall das kann man gar nicht anders
sagen er hat die gelegenheit beim schopf
gegriffen es war auch überfällig dass
mal ein hochrangiger deutscher vertreter
nach kiew reist und nachdem steinmeier
dort ja nicht gekommen ist hat ja auch
scholz beschlossen nicht hinzufahren
auch die außenministerin die ja
offensichtlich gerne fahren würde nimmt
im moment noch rücksicht innerhalb der
bundesregierung auf den kanzler und da
ist das für den oppositionsführer
natürlich eine gute gelegenheit auf der
einen seite dieses zeichen zu setzen und
den notwendigen besuch zu machen aber
natürlich auch innenpolitisch zu wirken
und zu sagen seht her ich mache das und
das ist ja dann auch die fortsetzung
gewesen sein politik im bundestag er hat
einen antrag gestellt eben für die
lieferung schwerer waffen und die ampel
regierung dann quasi dazu bewegt dass
sie einen eigenen antrag macht der
ähnlich lautete und damit mit dafür
gesorgt dass die ampel nun schwere
waffen liefern möchte wie sehen sie das
mit dieser reise er will jetzt
solidarität zeigen sie selber waren ja
auch in kiel weil die ersten deutsche
delegation sozusagen wie wichtig ist es
denn dorthin zu reisen um wirklich dann
zu wissen ja oder auf welcher basis man
dann entscheidungen trifft das macht
schon einen unterschied ob man sich vor
ort ein bild macht oder ob man nur die
nachrichten im fernsehen und in den
zeitungen verfolgt das ist schon auch
eine andere emotionale eindruck tja wenn
sie auf die menschen dort treffen und
merz hat sich ja auch mal nicht nur mit
politikern getroffen aber alpinen eine
der am schwersten umkämpften vororte die
massiv zerstört worden sind zu 70 80
prozent ich glaube das vermittelt schon
einen anderen eindruck und umgekehrt ist
es für die ukraine wichtig also selbst
via wir sind ja kleine lichter wir haben
kein politisches amt kann mandat wir
haben nur viele freunde partner in der
ukraine
sind mit offenen armen empfangen worden
als eine geste der solidarität also
dieses zeichen wir lassen euch nicht
allein
das hat eine enorme bedeutung in einer
solchen krieg situation in der ja auch
alle moralischen reserven mobilisieren
ukraine ja auch nicht allein er sorgt
für ganz viel hilfe und für ganz viel
geld trotzdem ist diese frage hin zu
reißen oder nicht auch eine frage ob man
aus der distanz heraus geht ob man aus
der reserve
herauskommt und ich finde das höchste
zeit dass diese diplomatischen
verstimmungen rund um die nicht reise
von steinmeier und dass die jetzt
aufgelöst werden das können wir uns
nicht leisten in einer kriegssituation
solche beleidigten spiele zu spielen das
war nicht klug von der ukrainischen
regierung ja aber darauf kann man nicht
ewig behalten nun muss jetzt bewegen ok
muss sich bewegen frau was finden sie
märz hat sich bewegt ist dorthin gereist
sollte sich der bundeskanzler jetzt auch
schnell nach kiew bewegen
ja definitiv und ich kann nur das
bekräftigen was vor quadbeck und herr
fuchs gerade sagten also die lage in der
ukraine ist ist dramatisch ich habe vor
weniger als zwei stunden steht mir ein
deutscher freund der in kiew hilft für
die organisation freedom to day der
gerade in der witz ist das ja in den
bunker geflüchtet ist und dies sind
heute abend fünf raketen abgefeuert
worden auf lisicki hat die zweite
tatsächlich gesehen kurz bevor er dann
im bunker war
und das ist schon wichtig dass erzählt
er mir auch die ganze zeit für die
ukraine zu sehen das ist auch deutsche
ford sind und man muss ja auch mal sich
vor augen führen wer längst alles da was
fahren mit lloyd austin der
verteidigungsminister nicht denken der
mit dem außenminister
so zahlt die höchsten derzeit eigentlich
wichtigsten ministerien das wichtigste
nato staats am usa in kiew live vor ort
von der leyen als kommissionspräsident
der bundespräsident wollte ja auch
deutschland
wollt ihr halten aber man muss natürlich
ja er wollte reisen er wollte sich aber
im grunde ein bisschen dran hängen an
angie du da
den den polnischen präsidenten und ohne
wirklich vorher mal was offen auch zu
sagen oder auch wirklich sehr sehr
deutlich zu sagen dass man die die spd
russland vergangenheit aufarbeiten
möchte und jetzt
verheddert man sich im grunde spd-intern
im kleinen kleinen der spiegel schrieb
heute morgen die zwei beleidigten
überstanden und stolz und das gibt schon
relativ desolate und bild ab und last
but not least weil ich das vorgeschlagen
wurde da vorgestellt wurde also ich sag
das nicht als cdu-mitglied ich habe
letztes jahr herr laschet oder monate
hart kritisiert also ich weil ich dachte
wirklich stolz wäre der bessere kanzler
dass es jemand dass deutschland durch
krisen führen kann und sehe das im
moment nicht so sondern im grunde sich
verheddern beleidigt sein herz hat recht
ja es war vielleicht diplomatisch unklug
von herrn melnik manches vielleicht auch
seitens der ukraine diese dieser
ausladung aber trotzdem dann muss man
eigentlich in so einer kriegssituation
als als deutschland auch ein bisschen
über seinen schatten springen und herr
van aken wie sehen sie denn dass der
botschafter den kanzler als beleidigte
leberwurst bezeichnet und unter dass der
bundespräsident eben nicht willkommen
war also wie sehr also sollte man also
wie schwierig macht das das miteinander
da jetzt gerade
also ich muß man sich echt mal zurecht
ruckeln also natürlich ist das nicht
wichtig viele von den dingen die herr
mixa das finde ich echt eigentlich ein
bisschen über die grenze aber auf der
anderen seite ist gerade krieg dort und
endlich kann man auch mal das ein
bisschen ergehen lassen das ist da jetzt
steinmeier und schaut sich das hin und
herschieben und weil der nicht mein
bester freund nicht das hört sich alles
am kindergarten das ist nicht richtig
auch wenn man werde ich auch fehler sie
beim 1
bei der chronischen regierung aber das
ist krieg und ich finde da muss man ganz
anders reagieren und deswegen finde ich
das mit der beleidigten leber groß das
ist genauso kindergarten macht muss auch
ein bisschen raus kommt und was finden
sie denn wie was würden sie denn sagen
was hat denn merz heute erreicht mit
dieser reise wie wichtig war es denn
dass der oppositionsführer dorthin
gereist ist
also die frage was er wollte also ich
finde solche reisen im prinzip immer
wichtig das sind ja eben auch schon
schon verschiedene gute gründe genannt
worden dass solidarität vor ort zeigen
das ist total wichtig habe ich selbst in
anderen situationen auch schon da macht
auch in kriegssituationen
man kann auch aus anderen gründen hin
vorhaben gregor gysi ist gerade dort um
dort humanitäre hilfe zu leisten und
sich zu erkundigen was die menschen in
butter und ihnen im moment noch an
humanitäre hilfe brauchen das sind alles
gute gründe und bei merz frage ich mich
die ganze zeit warum wenn das macht um
sich zu informieren um solidarität zu
zeigen es ist richtig und auf der
anderen seite stelle ich dann fest dass
er diese rolle verkündet auf der
pressekonferenz mit herrn wüst der
gerade wahlkampf ist und dann riecht das
ganze schon irgendwie nach
parteipolitischen trams und das ist dann
wieder völlig falsch also wenn er nur in
politischen gründen pferd und das nichts
wenn wir die menschen nicht nur gerade
zu tun hat dann finde ich ihnen dafür
richtig richtig böse also das denn nicht
mal ausgemacht ob im das war politisch
nutzt ja die deutsche öffentlichkeit ist
gespalten in der frage lieferung
schwerer waffen es gibt eine stimmung
auch der furcht wir werden in diesem
krieg hineingezogen ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob das wirklich als war
politisches kalkül
sagen aufging die cdu sie haben das
gesagt hat den antrag im bundestag
eingebracht also ich finde man kann
schon ernst nehmen dass es auch ein
außenpolitisches motiv für diese reise
gibt und ist natürlich legitim dass eine
opposition auch eine regierung unter
druck setzt was sonst
die lage ist auch zu ernst als dass man
sagen würde das ist reiner reiner
wahlkampf föderale reine parteitag
natürlich ist beim oppositionsführer
auch immer parteitaktik dabei ist ja nun
mal der schwächere sitzt nicht an den
hebeln der macht ich würde aber gerne
etwas zum thema beleidigte leberwurst
sagen man muss man überlegen warum ist
eigentlich so ist dass man diese
dieses diplomatische probleme nicht von
dem tisch gezogen bekommt und warum der
ukrainische botschafter jetzt eigentlich
noch mal nachgelegt hat der mann weiß ja
auch was er tut auf der einen seite kann
man sagen stolz ist nicht besonders
scharf darauf in die ukraine zu reisen
weil ihr müsst ihr irgendwie was
mitbringen und bisher ist die deutsche
hat sich die deutsche bundesregierung
nur sehr langsam bewegt im vergleich zu
anderen staaten was die sinne der
richtlinie entschlossen dass sie als sie
also langen entschlossen und
möglicherweise wäre jetzt auch der punkt
gewesen und dem scholz hätte reisen
können und dann geht wenig da so hart
rein vielleicht möchte man die
bundesregierung auch noch ein bisschen
länger quellen und zappeln lassen bevor
man dann sagt so jetzt machen wir den
diplomatischen korridor dafür auf also
dass man tatsächlich warum auch immer
ich weiß nicht ob als als symbol oder
als strafaktion oder auch die
bundesregierung unter druck zu setzen
noch mehr zu tun erst mal den korridor
für die oppositionsführer aufgemacht hat
also wenig kennt sich ja in berlin
hinreichend gut aus dass er ganz genau
weiß auf knöpfe drücken muss um was zu
erreichen merck hat ja klar gesagt er
hat bestimmte dinge besprochen auch mit
dem präsidenten die er noch nicht auf
einer pressekonferenz sagen wollte
sondern eben erst mit dem bundeskanzler
besprechen will das also da versucht er
ja eigentlich so ein sozusagen so nach
dem motto als wäre er teile dieses ganz
auf der der kollegen hatte ich nicht den
eindruck dass da ganz so viel ist was er
an botschaften mitzubringen hat aber
okay aber sie sagen trotzdem ist es
eigentlich dass er dafür frau bednarz
bitte
wenn ich noch zwei punkte kurz ergänzen
darf es ist ja nicht nur die nicht reise
von scholz man darf er nicht vergessen
marie agnes strack zimmermann hat ja nun
sehr deutlich in den medien kundgetan
dass diese gemeinsame reise von ihr und
michael roth von der spd und anton
hofreiter aus dem kanzleramt nicht
erwünscht war also sie sagt ja sogar in
einer talkshow es habe dann zwar nicht
von scholz persönlich aber doch vom
feinsten vertrauten geheißen das war
kriegs tourismus und das bekommt die
ukraine natürlich auch mit also es ist
jetzt sozusagen das ist nicht nur
hinreise sondern auch andere davon
abhalten und kurz noch zur cdu man muss
natürlich auch sehen und welcher
tradition die cdu steht ist eine partei
für die die selbstbindung ganz ganz
zentral ist immer war herr merz war bis
vor kurzem vorsitzender der atlantik
brücke also sprich die das ganze
transatlantische verhältnis hatte auch
noch mal höheren wert dass das muss man
auch berücksichtigen insofern würde ich
jetzt auch mir ist nicht zu leicht
machen und jetzt einfach nur
wahltaktische momente unterstellen
sondern eigentlich auch dieser ansicht
bekräftigen dass das
verantwortungsbewusstsein muss man aber
auch sagen dass die cdu ja nur mit frau
merkel 16 jahre diesen kurs auch
gegenüber russland ja gefahren hat herr
fuchs müssten dann nicht auch also so
streng wie man ist mit der spd und mit
herrn steinmeier müsste man nicht
ähnlich ist auch eine zumindest eine
äußerung der bundeskanzlerin mal
erwarten der ehemalige bundeskanzler ja
ich respektiere wenn sie sagt ich bin
jetzt keine öffentliche keine politische
person mehr ich würde mir das wünschen
dass sie sich verhält aber
ist mal ist es eine sache der cdu die
muss auch einen kurswechsel vollziehen
nicht nur sagen die spd
frau merkel hat tatsächlich die ukraine
auch auf abstand gehalten sie war
maßgeblich mitverantwortlich dafür dass
ihr ein nato mitgliedschaft verweigert
wurde sie hat auch den europäischen
beitritt der ukraine immer abgewehrt sie
hat waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
abgewehrt die ja schon lange vor dem
krieg ein thema waren man muss die
ukraine so aufrüsten dass das möglichst
abschreckende wirkung lang auf russland
hat also das ist schon auch eine
politische verantwortung
der cdu ja nicht nur der spd davon hat
man immer von einem arzt auch nichts
gehört davon irgendwie sehen sie dafür
sehen sie die rolle der cdu im volk also
in der russland politik und die
sicherheits dann verhält
weil die ganze kritik ich ja immer gegen
die idee
grundsätzlich unterschiedliche
motivationen bei der cdu war es ja
hauptsächlich der wirtschaftsflügel der
den letzten jahren und jahrzehnten immer
möglichst enge verbindungen an russland
haben wollte und die wiederum die eben
aus der west bildung stammten haben in
den letzten jahren die sanktionen wie
viele worte das heißt da die cdu war
gespalten die spd ist glaube ich
tendenziell eher in richtung auch aus
ihrer friedens tradition kommt aus der
entspannungs politik von von willy
brandt egon bahr kommt weil sie glaube
ich noch mal stärker sozusagen auf einen
kooperationskurs dass ich ja richtig
fand aber das genauso und steckten sie
bis zum hals natürlich in dieser energie
partnerschaft mit russland das ist
maßgeblich von spd leuten betrieben
worden llanos dem 12 der ausverkauf der
gasspeicher das waren es wurde sehr
steigen nicht aber nicht dass schröder
da ist eine ganze spd seilschaft ein
ganzes netzwerk was systematisch diese
ich würde sagen ausverkauf der deutschen
energie sicherheit an russland betrieben
hat und es gibt noch die qualitativen
unterschied zwischen der
gibt noch einen qualitativen unterschied
zwischen russland politik der union und
der spd
bei der spd gab es immer diese kumpanen
und diese enge bindung ja dieses
kompromittierende fotos steinmeier live
auf den abend und das war schon so dass
merkel da immer sehr offensichtlich die
distanz zu putin gehalten hat wer war
körperlich sowieso und sie war immerhin
die ich meine minsk war galt damals
schon als erfolg und sie war diejenige
die den deckel drauf bekommen hat sich
nicht nachhaltig darauf bekommen wie wir
jetzt wissen aber sie hat das schon
schon ausgehandelt und ich glaube herr
van aken sie wollten das noch macht ja
nichts wo sie sind ja hier damit man
miteinander reden also alles gut herüber
nagen sie wollten jetzt nochmals nach
sätzen und so entzückend
das war genau der punkt also ich war
noch nicht zu ende ist unterbrochen hat
das genau der punkt dass sie eben nicht
behalten war und dass man nicht
vergessen darf dass es die
merkel-regierung weil die menschen
ausgehandelt hat und es war zu der zeit
ein richtiger erfolg das sind beide
seiten sich nicht mehr angehalten haben
von anfang an sich ist eine andere
geschichte aber erstmal muss man sagen
gab es in europa niemand der sozusagen
immer noch versucht hatten hinzubekommen
und erst mal erfolgreich also ich glaube
es sind beide parteien
regierungsparteien der letzten jahre
gewesen die dort
verbracht hat dann gehen wir hier alle
gemacht haben nämlich zu denken ja
möglicherweise greift brust nativen
kreis werden aber wahrscheinlich ist es
auf dem don was beschreibt und das ist
denn nun das ganze land ging das haben
die allerwenigsten so gesehen ich habe
auch immer was wird sich denn was könnte
sich jetzt ändern frau kurt beck nach
dieser reise von merz könnte das sein
dass es jetzt noch mal sozusagen noch
eine verschärfung gibt zwischen
opposition und bundesregierung was den
kurs gegenüber der ukraine betrifft oder
könnte sogar sein dass man näher
zusammenrückt also näher zusammenrücken
sich nicht unbedingt die ampel regierung
insbesondere die spd ist in die
defensive getrieben
ich rechne damit dass ist nicht mehr
allzu lange dauern wird dass auch frau
berbalk in die ukraine reist sie hat das
ja schon angekündigt und sie wird sich
das nicht mehr allzu lange anschauen
nicht mehr allzu lange rücksicht nehmen
aber heute sogar äußert dass er sehr
unglücklich findet dass das regierung
sondern nicht den grünen und den grund
tut das richtig weh dass ich nicht so
handeln können wie sie handeln wie sie
handeln möchten in diesem fall und da
wird es mit der loyalität innerhalb der
regierung also das ist so die die
baustelle die die ampel jetzt hat und
bei scholz wird es noch eine weile
dauern weil nach der beleidigten
leberwurst ist das ja noch mal ein stück
in die in die ferne gerückt und wie
gesagt das ist auch tatsächlich ein
problem für ihn weil er ja nicht als
komplett getriebener dort hinfahren kann
es muss ja immer noch so aussehen als
sei es seine entscheidung als würde aus
freien stücken fahren und im moment wenn
er jetzt was ich in den nächsten zehn
tagen fährt dann wäre er natürlich der
getriebene einmal von der opposition und
eben auch vom ukrainischen botschafter
man hat ja jeder stolz jetzt von
verschiedenen seiten immer unter druck
steht also erst unter sehr stark unter
druck dass er mehr waffen liefern sollte
und schneller dann gibt es jetzt aber
auch eine starke initiative erfolgs die
in einem offenen brief haben prominente
ja gefordert dass es eben keine waffen
liefern dass man keine waffen liefern
solle aus angst vor einem atomkrieg und
da die petition haben glaube ich
inzwischen über 200.000 leute schon
unterschrieben also wie getrieben ist
der kanzler da von beiden seiten
was jetzt gefragt ist das politische
führung ja das ist im grunde eine frage
seiner eigenen souveränen entscheidungen
warum muss er sich daran orientieren was
der ukrainische botschafter sagt oder
was herr merz sagen in kiew sagt es ist
seine verantwortung ist eine politische
entscheidung die er zu treffen hat wie
er jetzt dieses verhältnis mit der
ukraine wieder begradigt
das ist schon so dass nicht nur einen
augen vieler ukrainerinnen sondern auch
viele unserer partner in mittelosteuropa
auch in den usa deutschland mit dieser
ewigen zögerlichen und halbherzigen
politik ja dieses nur unter druck
jeweils den nächsten schritt gehen ob
dass waffenlieferungen nicht ganz
anderen nachdem der menschen die diesen
brief geschrieben haben die gesagt haben
die gefahr ist so groß dass wir dass wir
da uns zurückhalten sollten natürlich
verstehe ich die furcht vor allem
atomkrieg wer hätte die nicht irgendwo
im hinterkopf ich halte das aber
in der sache für völlig verfehlt
erstens sitzen im kreml ist eine bande
von selbstmordattentätern die nur darauf
warten sich selbst und die ganze welt in
die luft zu sprengen sondern die testen
wie weit sie gehen können ohne auf
entschiedenen widerstand des westens zu
treffen und das zweite argument ist wenn
wir uns diese erpressung beugen dann
überlassen wir putin vollständig die
eskalation dominanz in der in der
ukraine dann entscheidet immer eher wie
weit er geht und möglicherweise auch
über die ukraine hinaus das kann nicht
der maßstab unserer politik aber ist es
denn herr van aken richtig auf diese
erpressung mit mehr waffenlieferungen zu
reagieren ist das die richtige antwort
ich finde dass die falsche antwort ich
kenne diesen appell übrigens auch falsch
weil einfach nur zu sagen keine waffen
zu liefern reicht nicht wir haben jetzt
gesehen dass der kreml bereiteten bei
land zu überfallen und wenn jetzt
überhaupt nicht reagiert ist das nächste
und das übernächste land auch daran dass
heißt es geht schon darum jetzt den
preis für den kreml in die höhe zu
treiben aber ich möchte das nicht nur
militärisch denken ich möchte endlich
auch mal an weil ich möchte nicht über
reisen von ähnlichen politikern reden
ich möchte endlich mal drüber reden wie
wir anders als mit waffen möglicherweise
den druck auf den krümmel so weit
erhöhen können dass er zu einer
richtigen verhandlungen gerechten
frieden bereit ist und es wird viel zu
wenig über über andere arten zu über
bessere sanktionen diskutiert und vor
allem über diplomatie gar nicht und
damit meine ich nicht aber ein lang
herrscht zu setzen damit ich wen gibt es
der welt die man einbinden könnte ich
habe mich so geärgert das war vor
wenigen tagen stolz nach japan fliegt
jetzt 28 stunden im flugzeug und landet
nicht mal für zwei stunden zwischen in
peking um zu versuchen da der gemeinsame
initiative hin zu bekommen denn da gibt
es ein großes interesse dass dieser
krieg bald zu ende ist aber die würden
sie denn sagen es hat keinen sinn mehr
sich mit putin an diesem langen tisch zu
setzen weil das genau haben wir haben
wir die europäischen präsidenten ja
gemacht bevor und dann kam es eben am 24
februar zum überfall also das macht auch
keinen sinn mehr
das macht überhaupt keinen sinn mehr
aber die welt ist doch größer als nur
russland und
china hat überhaupt kein interesse an
diesem konflikt sie hatten auch
kritisiert
andererseits wird china russland niemals
in den rücken fallen das wissen wir alle
aber mit sicherheit sehr offen für eine
dieser titel aus eu und china
meinetwegen und ich sage immer ganz klar
die lenski möchte sein acht wochen
endlich direkt mit putin verhandeln wenn
jean ping in peking einlädt dann kommt
putin auch die frau bednarz was würden
sie sagen wie wichtig ist es jetzt erst
mal den forderungen den wünschen der
ukraine nachzukommen eben doch viel mehr
war von zu liefern obwohl auch viele
menschen in deutschland das sehr
kritisch sehen
also sicherlich kann man auch über
weitere sanktionen sprechen oder auch
versuchen auf ihn einzuwirken dass sich
auch das eher skeptisch sehe was die
erfolgsaussichten angehen aber man muss
doch jetzt mal schauen welche signale
sendet dann putin diplomatisch als gut
harris der un generalsekretär in gefahr
ist kombiniert worden zur gleichen zeit
der papst leppelt fast um eine audienz
bei putin und bekommt ziemlich es geht
ab teil durch die medien also dass putin
ernsthaft verhandeln möchten sehe ich
nicht es gibt die ganze zeit über
bilaterale verhandlungen auf anderem
darunter liegenden level ja durchaus
zwischen der ukraine und russland
und nicht zuletzt es ist ein krieg und
ein krieg wird tatsächlich im moment
primär durch durch waffen entschieden
und man hat es gesehen der ukraine ist
es gelungen in kiew die russen
zurückzudrängen und im moment ist die
militärische lage im sommer so dass
diese offensive der russen nicht gut
funktioniert der russische
generalstabschef war jetzt gerade in der
ost ukraine ist dort fast von ukrainern
getötet von alleine dass er sich dorthin
begibt macht eigentlich ein
generalstabschef nicht zeigt wie prekär
die lage ist russland hat ungefähr ein
fünftel von insgesamt 120 bataillons
verloren das hat 260 kampf kaum verstand
zwanzigster april und man sieht auch
jetzt kein echtes vorkommen also die faz
schreibt heute dass kampf verhältnis
russischer soldaten ukrainischen das
etwa 1 zu 2 ist von zwei russen auf
einen ukrainischen soldaten alle
militärs sagen morgen mindestens denn
der g-20 kaum wert schon eins zu drei
also nicht mal das wird erreicht und die
ukraine während sich das heißt jetzt ist
eigentlich die chance die russen
zurückzudrängen sie militärisch auch so
zu sprechen dass sie nicht in moldau
einmarschieren kann womit ein russischer
general major letzten freitag erst
gedroht hat und das wird eben nur mit
schweren waffen funktionieren
und jetzt hat heute die bundesregierung
ja oft mal die entscheidung getroffen
panzerhaubitze 2000 zu liefern das ist
wirklich sehr sehr schwerer artillerie
und man muss ihn zumindest militärische
so schlecht damit man mit ihm verhandeln
kann also insofern ja schwere fragen ob
das so funktioniert die große angst ist
ja friedberg dass man kriegspartei wird
sind wir nicht schon längst kriegspartei
weil wir halt eben einiges jahr schon
liefern auch schon viel liefern na ja
das interessante ist ja dass am ende
putin derjenige ist der definiert wer
kriegspartei ist also die windungen des
völkerrechts dazu die interessieren
putin ja herzlich wenig und in dem
moment in dem er total mit dem rücken
zur wand steht kann das immer passieren
dass er sagt ihr seid jetzt kriegspartei
oder die variante dass er den dollars zu
russischem staatsgebiet erklärt und
daraus dann ableitet dass er nun eine
generalmobilmachung
los treten kann um eben sein land zu
verteidigen
also deshalb die frage ob wir
kriegspartei sind da liegen wir komplett
in putins hand und deshalb ist es auch
nicht so wichtig ob wir nun den panzer
liefern oder den anderen panzer sondern
putin wird das als ultima ratio aus
seiner sicht also das ist doch das
argument der bundesregierung ist man auf
keinen fall creek partei werden möchte
das ist doch das argument um durch eines
der vielen vorgeschobene argumente warum
wir so lange keine schweren waffen haben
würden seien vorgeschoben ja ok in dem
völkerrechtlichen sinne sind wir nicht
kriegspartei seinen waffenlieferungen an
einen angegriffenen souveränen staat
politisch würde ich sagen ja das ist
auch unser krieg ich würde sogar einen
schritt sagen weiter gehen ja dass das
war immer ein bisschen die
zweideutigkeit vor allem in der
kommunikation
sagen des kanzlers ich würde erwarten
dass er sagt ja die ukraine kämpft auch
für uns sie kämpft auch für die
sicherheitsinteressen deutschlands und
für die demokratische zukunft europas
und deshalb werden wir alles tun
damit sie sich erfolgreich gegen diesen
angriff behaupten kann das wäre aus
meiner sicht man endlich ein politischer
befreiungsschlag
und dann kann man darüber diskutieren
was sind jetzt die besten mittel das zu
tun aber eher das ist auch unsere sache
ja wann dann muss man darüber überlegen
was am ende stehen soll also wo am ende
soll stehen eine politisch souveräne
dank ukraine dient ihr reale
unserem inklusive don bass und krim das
hat ja selbst zellen ski nicht gefordert
zielinski hat für ukrainische
verhältnisse das war durchaus ein
gewagtes manöver gesagt statt trister
grimm 15 jahre einfrieren und wir
erwarten auch nicht dass die
russischen marionetten republiken im
donbass sofort unter ukrainische
souveränität zurück kehren im grunde hat
er gesagt status quo vor dem 23 februar
und die ukraine verzichtet auf einen
nato beitritt das war das angebot ja und
dem ist nie ein adäquates
gegenangebot von seiten sagen russlands
verfolgt man muss einfach ich ernst
nehmen dass das ziel putins ist die
eigenständigkeit der ukraine als nation
und staat zu zerstören und das davon auf
keinen fall tolerieren
das heißt immer die ukraine muss diesen
krieg gewinnen oder russland daneben
nicht gewinnen ich will natürlich
gewinnen er trotzdem noch mal fragen was
das für uns bedeutet frau bednarz wenn
man und wie die regierung der agieren
soll wenn man auch sieht dass die
bevölkerung ja eigentlich gespalten ist
in dieser beurteilung also nach der
letzten umfrage von infratest dimap sind
45 prozent dafür für die lieferung von
schweren waffen das sind wenige zehn
prozent weniger als vor noch zwei drei
wochen und dagegen sind auch 45 prozent
also wie soll eine regierung damit
umgehen
also ammann regierung das wurde ja auch
schon gesagt muss führen und muss dann
in so einer prekären lage die richtigen
entscheidungen treffen und darf sich
nicht von umfragen treiben lassen die
natürlich auch durch solche obskuren
offenen briefe wie jetzt wird ja auch
die meinung beeinflusst aber davon darf
man sich im grunde als oder muss man
sich als vergebung irgendwo auch
freimachen wer übrigens falls sich das
so deutlich sagen darf jetzt seitens der
cdu gewaltig mit zündet ist kretzschmar
der sächsische ministerpräsident
der sich hinter diesen offenen briefs
gerade gestellt hat bei einer
präsidiumssitzung der cdu
montag also gestern und auch gesagt hat
im grunde die veröffentlichte meinung
würde nicht unbedingt der öffentlichen
meinung entsprechen und damit im grunde
auch dieser sichtweise nahrung gibt dass
das volk ja angeblich ganz anders denkt
sodann das ist schon relativ
populistischer diskurs und im grunde ist
eigentlich gerade von jemandem wie
scholz striktes rationales denken
gefordert und das muss man erst drin ist
wer diese waffen frage also man also
interessanterweise und osteuropa guard
in polen ist die angst davor eigentlich
kaum vorhanden weil man es realistisch
sieht denn was kann passieren also putin
könnte taktischen nuklearwaffen um damit
gewiss städte in der ukraine zu
bombardieren das glaube ich dass wachsen
muss passieren könnte selbst das ist
eher unwahrscheinlich dass wir mit einem
halb verseucht wir haben
alle haben gesagt ist es komplett
unwahrscheinlich dass er nach dass er
kiew an greift also wir also das finde
ich ganz schwierig jetzt ich würde ja ja
aber die arbeit der angriff nur ganz
kurz nur der angriff auf kiew sozusagen
der gefährdet ihn nicht unmittelbar also
sollte putin jetzt wirklich anfangen
massiven atom anschlag durchzuführen
wäre doch wäre ja klar was passieren
würde dann folgt dagegen stark und dann
und zwar in russland da würde die nato
nicht tatenlos zusehen deswegen halte
ich das ehrlich gesagt eher für eine
abstrakte angst und man darf es nicht
diese angst auch nicht hingeben und
erpressen lassen weil erkannt im grunde
mit dieser drogen mit dem atomkrieg
trotzdem hausen man ja überlegen dann
muss man überlegen wie man damit umgeht
das halt eben doch auch viele menschen
große probleme mit haben wir haben es
auch bei der kundgebung zum beispiel
beim dgb am ersten mai wo sie der
kanzler ausgepfiffen wurde als
kriegstreiber beschimpft herr van aken
was würden sie da wie geht man damit um
dass es natürlich eine pazifistische
strömungen gibt es gibt ostermarschierer
die wurden auch als fünfte kolonne
putins auf einmal beschimpft also wie
soll man das jetzt also wie schaffen wir
das auf der einen seite die ukraine zu
unterstützen auf der anderen seite zu
sehen
dass wir das was wir in dieser
gesellschaft uns da nicht völlig
auseinander dividieren lassen
also ich glaube was man nicht
unterschätzen das ist dass ganz viele
menschen tragen haben ich bin jetzt seit
mehreren wochen überall in deutschland
unterwegs hat sich veranstaltung vor ort
ganz unterschiedliche art und die
meisten menschen haben fragen viele
tendieren auch dazu er waffen zu liefern
aber wissen auch nicht so richtig und
diese fragen werden um endlich
beantwortet wenn ich mir den letzten
acht wochen den öffentlichen diskurs in
deutschland anschaue und dass diese
sendung wirklichen ganz große ausnahme
gab es eigentlich nur noch die
diskussion um schwere noch schwere oder
superschwere lassen und sobald jemand
sagte könnte auch mal über andere arten
von sanktionen reden oder immer gesagt
da reden wir nicht drüber es geht um
waffen das ist krieg also auch frau
betten hat das gerade eben gesagt und
ich glaube sie unterliegt einen großen
irrtum kriege alle kriege der letzten 30
40 50 jahre alle kriege sind nur mit
verhandlungen zu ende gegangen wir
stellen also gerade eigentlich die frage
wie können wir den kreml endlich zu
bewegen einen gerechten frieden mit
auszuhandeln und dafür brauchen die
druck da bin ich völlig bei ihnen aber
das darf man doch nicht nur militärisch
denken wenn man nur militärisch steckt
konnten sich all die kriege an da war
sie fünf jahre zehn jahre weil wenn man
nur militärisch denkt hören die seiten
erst auch zu kämpfen wenn beide seiten
kriegsmüde sind und das dauert sehr
lange dann reden wir über ein szenario
afghanistan das kann niemand wollen und
deswegen sich mit wünschen weil eben
auch die die fragen bei den menschen
hier in deutschland da sind das immer
sehr viel mehr zeit haben um über
gezielte sanktionen an alle 20.000
multimillionäre warum reden wir erst
jetzt über öl und heute immer noch nicht
beschlossen aber auch
darüber dass
gemacht
das ist ein neoliberales land der
braucht die kapital fraktion das m20
1000 multimillionäre die dort den daten
im griff haben und gegen die gibt es
überhaupt keine sanktionen hier
deutschland gar nichts werden die villen
am starnberger see nicht beschlagnahmen
das findet alles nicht sondern nur gegen
halbe handvoll oligarchen und ich glaube
da sollten wir darüber reden ob der
fuchs also wenn man putin ökonomisch
kräften will wenn man dem regime die
finanziellen ressourcen für den krieg
entziehen will dann muss man den
russischen energiesektor sanktionieren
das sind 40 prozent der staatseinnahmen
das sind zwei drittel der exporterlöse
alle pazifisten müssen im grunde dafür
seien dann wenigstens harte ökonomische
sanktionen gegen russische öl- und
gasexporte zu verhängen aber ihren
vermarkten ich meine der krieg da hat ja
liane bett das recht der krieg wird
zunächst einmal
militärisch ausgetragen und wir müssen
verhindern dass russland mit seiner
jetzigen offensive im süden und osten
der ukraine erfolg hat und es schafft
einen landkorridor von h g bis a zu
erobern weil das wäre dann
voraussichtlich die grenze für die
nächsten jahre eine neue teilung der
ukraine und dafür muss man die
ukrainische armee so stark machen dass
sie diesen angriff abwehren kann sie
glauben die können das auch gewinnen die
ukraine sind davon überzeugt weil sie
sagen wir haben die überlegene moral wir
wissen wofür wir kämpfen wir kämpfen in
unserem eigenen land aber wir brauchen
dafür eine militärische ausrüstung die
uns instand setzt dieser russischen
materialschlacht standzuhalten
frau quadbeck wie würden sie es
beurteilen wie schafft man das dass man
eben die bevölkerung der zusammenhält in
deutschland wenn wenn man so gespalten
ist und jetzt haben wir ein ganz zeit
immer über diese schweren waffen in den
letzten wochen gesprochen aber jetzt
gibt immer hat man jetzt für es gibt auf
einmal eine art gegenbewegung
also dieses unbehagen das hat
möglicherweise nicht nur mit dem thema
waffenlieferung zu tun was immer ein
thema ist was zur spaltung führt weil
das ja auch immer eine sehr sehr
schwierige abwägung ist auch wenn meine
linie jetzt im fall der ukraine da sehr
klar wäre dass wir die waffen liefern
müssen
die leute spüren inzwischen die
inflation sehr stark vor allen dingen
die mit den kleinen und mittleren
einkommen und jetzt hat die
bundesregierung so ein paar dinge auf
den weg gebracht die aus meiner sicht
überhaupt nicht zielgenau sind bis 9
euro ticket was irgendwie alle bekommen
sollen egal welches gehalt ja und was
die leute auf dem land nicht nutzen
können dann ist ja immer noch im raum
dass wir den
steuer für den sprit für eine zeitlang
senken auch das ist komplett mit der
gießkanne und da wäre es zum beispiel
wenn die über politische führung
sprechen eigentlich auch angezeigt dass
man wirklich den leuten hilft dies am
meisten trifft diese inflation und dass
diejenigen bei denen nur die persönliche
sparquote etwas geringer ausfällt dass
die natürlich das eben tragen müssen und
es wird den leuten dann auch nicht genug
reiner wein eingeschenkt
wir haben in 16 jahren merkel gelernt
macht euch mal keine sorgen ich halte
alle nöte außenpolitisch wie
innenpolitisch von euch ab
außenpolitisch zeigt sich das irgendwie
und innenpolitisch wird das alles mit
geld zugeschüttet wir sind an einem
punkt an dem das nicht mehr funktioniert
außenpolitisch haben wir die lage nicht
im griff und innenpolitisch wird das
geld nicht reichen um alles was an
schaden durch diesen krieg auch bei uns
angerichtet wird auszugleichen und da
müsste man muss nicht gleich eine blut
schweiß und tränen rede halten aber
müsste etwas er ja dass man sehr sagt er
werden ärmer werden oder viele wäre es
aber auch wirklich der einzige der
ehrlich ist aber von herrn scholz habe
ich dazu noch kein besonders ehrliches
wort gehört und der finanzminister das
ist mal ganz entdeckung
gucken wie man das ja der sich aber die
haben sich heute geäußert dann haben
eigentlich gesagt es wird wieder mehr
bereitgestellt werden
aber wie gesagt so einen neuen euro
ticket wird nicht das ausgleichen was
die inflation den rentner und
rentnerinnen und den leuten mit den
kleinen einkommen raubt das ist weiße
salbe ok und nichts wie genau
was wäre denn jetzt wichtig also herr
merz heute in kiew hat klar hat viel
aufmerksamkeit bekommen in unsere presse
und auch natürlich auch in der ukraine
jetzt wird er sich mit herrn scholz
treffen und ihm dann davon erzählen was
würden sie sagen herr fuchs was wären
jetzt in den nächsten tagen wochen was
wäre das wichtigste was die
bundesregierung tun sollte oder was
bundeskanzler scholz dann auch sollte
zum einen finde ich dass wir diesen
bundestagsbeschluss jetzt in die praxis
umsetzen müssen und zwar schnell in ein
kriegsheld zeit da kommt es auf
geschwindigkeit auch an des handelns zum
anderen würde ich mich gerne anschließen
braucht es eine andere kommunikation es
braucht eine andere ansprache auch an
die eigene bevölkerung zu sein dieser
krieg wird auch nicht spurlos an uns
vorbei gehen und wir werden alles tun um
die lasten möglichst sozial gerecht und
fair zu verteilen und des schwächeren
einkommensgruppen wir uns gerade
bevölkerungen ja so schön heißt es in
einer anderen kommune kanzler eine
andere kommunikation und zu sagen was
auf dem spiel steht ja das will ich die
europäische friedensordnung auf dem
spiel steht die sicherheit auch der
bundesrepublik und die zukunft der
europäischen demokratie und dass wir
dafür auch bereit sein müssen opfer zu
bringen ok hätten was würden sie sich
erhoffen oder wünschen gibt es
vielleicht nochmal eine neue dynamik
auch durch die reise von merz
ich glaube nicht durch die reise von
merz somit muss endlich dynamik
reinkommen und das mit der eile da gebe
ich ja ein recht man muss schnell
handeln stand heute abend hat seit
beginn des krieges in den letzten acht
neun wochen die europäische union
48,3 milliarden euro nach moskau oder
wesen nur für kohle gas öl acht wochen
lang 48,3 milliarden euro das ist nicht
schnell handeln das ist langsames
handeln es gibt so viele gute vorschläge
auf den tisch wie sie auch hier schnell
was einsparen können warum machen wir
immer noch keinen kein öl embargo warum
wird nicht viel intensiver das gas
embargo vorbereitet stattdessen werden
waffen geliefert und ich finde dass mit
dem 48 milliarden die die 300 ein
bruchteil davon bekommen ist doch
ungerecht also der angreifer krieg
zehnmal so viele wieder angegriffen das
ist nicht solidarität mit den menschen
in der ukraine deswegen finde ich
schleunigst auf dem gebiet handeln und
nicht immer nur überraschen reden das
ist der falsche aber sie sagen
stattdessen werden waffengesetz heißt
sie werden wirklich explizit dafür dass
wir dann keine schweren waffen liefern
in dieser momenten dieser situation
jetzt liefern wir keine ich bin im
moment gegen waffenlieferungen wo wir
die anderen wege noch nicht mal
ausprobiert haben wo wir immer noch
jeden tag hunderte von millionen nach
moskau überweisen und weise die ganze
kriegsmaschinerie wird finanzieren in
der situation denn waffen an die grenze
entfernt ist doch eigentlich unsinn das
müsste doch allen klar sein wenn wir den
gegner die ganze zeit
die wir haben sind fast am ende der
sendung bednarz
ja nur ganz kurz was passiert dann wenn
die ukraine jetzt einfach schub erhält
also dann führt das dazu dass putin
tatsächlich gewinnen kann im don was
also das ist ja nicht so dass und im
moment setzte man jetzt hier den gashahn
zudrehen würde das dann herr putin
aufhört dort sein dass soldaten
weiterkämpfen zu lassen also wie soll
die ukraine sich denn ohne waffen
marschroute ernsthaft wären also sie
werden sozusagen für beides waffen und
gas-embargo richtig oder
weil war unbeleuchtet einfach nur diese
sichtweise jaja aber mir leuchtet
einfach diese sichtweise nicht an ihr zu
sagen wir liefern einfach nicht sie
braucht nachschub braucht panzerfäuste
sie braucht all diese waffen um auch die
gegnerischen panzern zu zerschießen also
das halte ich wenn ich das sagen darf
einfach für für etwas lebensfremd zu
glauben dass man das alleine mit
funktion stadt dafür ist es so akut die
kämpfe dauern ja an hervorragend war
noch ganz kurz dazu
sie werden das mit den börsen nicht
beenden und die entscheidung über wie
die friedensförderung ausgehen das hat
auch ganz viel mit sanktionen und
ökonomie zu tun wenn ist im kreml wehtut
sind sie auch zu zugeständnissen bereit
egal welche städte sie im moment erobern
das ganze ist das feature militärisch
gedacht dass wir frau berg ganz sagt wir
müssen den blick weiten weg zur
militärischen okay das sehen sie anders
als sechster wurden sie ganz klar sagen
wir müssen jetzt die waffen liefern dass
es ihre positive haben ja die ukraine
überhaupt noch standhalten kann und
nicht zu sagen zusammenbricht weil die
sanktionen bewirken mittel und
langfristig der krieg wird
kurzfristig entschieden
ganz herzlichen dank für die diskussion
flottbek effekt fuchs und herr van aken
vielen dank irgendwas zu schauen und wir
haben jetzt ja schon eine mehrmals
angesprochen energie und öl embargo
darüber reden wir morgen in dieser
phoenix runde also sozusagen die
fortsetzung seien sie gerne wie dabei
hier geht es weiter mit phoenix der tag
bis dann tschüss
[Musik]